here's just a slide about who I am a lot
of Bio background is more online
um I'll have the slides available
afterwards actually this is part of a
larger slide deck and I I want to just
give a little preface about graph data
science so here
um I showed this example in other talks
before but just two slides briefly let's
think about having a medieval village
somewhere in the Black Forest back in
the Middle Ages and here we've got seven
villagers they all have cottage
industries Pat runs the pub Hannah works
the fields Brenda runs the brewery on
and on but just in the scope here of
like seven cottage industries seven
individuals we can represent a circular
economy and we can show that like Chris
buys eggs from Thomas and flower from
Iden and makes bread to sell to Pat at
the pub
um Now using that kind of graph
representation you might come in and do
some questions some data science work
like for instance Which business is most
influential and frankly you know when
I've shown this example to business
people a lot of them immediately point
to Hana and say oh she's going to make a
killing and actually if you run uh
there's a graph algorithm called between
a centrality it shows that Hana has the
highest rank what that means is she's in
the midst of deal flow she's really
Central when it comes to business in
this Village
so um this is an idea of using graphs to
be able to get insights inference uh
using graph data science there's a much
larger article about this it's called
graph thinking
so uh the general category here what I'm
talking about is is graph data science
Making inference with graphs there's a
lot of different useful Technologies a
lot that's open source unfortunately
they're they're kind of divided in a lot
of different camps so you've got the
people doing axiomatic w3c sorts of
things that are provable you've got
people doing statistical relational
learning which are probabilistic or
causality kinds of graphs you've got
people doing visualizations people doing
deep learning on and on and on
Unfortunately they don't really go to
the same conferences they don't talk to
each other much their software really
doesn't talk to each other and our team
identified
about three years ago that this was a
real big problem we were working on
graphs for natural language and it was
just so hard to integrate the different
open source libraries so we started
working on a pi data-ish abstraction
layer in Python to be able to integrate
a lot of these and you know have a
common abstraction it's called kg lab
we'll show a little bit later
I want to give some primary sources
always and there's some great background
here if you want to look at where
knowledge graphs have come from and just
kind of the general category some of
this stretches back into like the 18th
century with Charles Thunder's prayers
um in terms of the math there's
definitely a lot of graph Theory and
related math
um and there's some other areas too like
category theory that comes pretty close
to it but and topology also I should say
um you know typically they talk about a
graph you'll see this equation where a
graph is basically two sets put together
it's a set of vertices and a set of the
edges that connect them
and there's an especially popular area
of this math that barbasi and Albert
came up with long ago called 20 years
ago it's called Uh random scale free
networks and it's been a lot of math
proven about it really interesting
unfortunately it doesn't really take
into account the kind of graph data that
we encounter in industry in use cases
um because this math doesn't take into
account properties like you'd see in a
label property graph or probabilities
like you'd see in some sort of
statistical relational learning or
motifs like you'd see in terms of motif
prediction and using deep learning to
analyze for patterns that repeat within
a graph
so I I just want to give the caveat that
if you're reading the math the math is
kind of out of sync with the practice
um and I've talked a lot of good
mathematicians about this too there's
definitely some opportunities but just
keep in mind
there's the practice of what you do in
graph data science they're the open
source projects they're the vendors
there's the math and they're all kind of
disconnected
um you're going to see a whole lot of
stuff about w3c and rdf and also about
labeled property graphs it's more like
the commercial vendors
um there are some ways to try to unify
these that may or may not be working and
have been in progress for a long time
there's also probabilistic graphs that
none of the above really handle so
industry use cases that we run into
typically combine these three parts
semantic data graphs and probabilistic
and not a lot of commercial support for
that but there is some good open source
uh just real quick here's a list of like
different graph database vendors also
different Consulting shops small shops
that have experts in particular areas
um you know we welcome more to help
curate this list if you have anything to
add
um takeaway is there's more than 50
graph database vendors
and there's some very large scale
projects out of China working with like
hundreds of trillions of edges
um so a lot of interesting stuff going
on there
now this talk is mostly about data prep
for graphs and here's the problem
um when you're doing data preparation
work in data science you know we talk
about this Pareto rule where it's like
80 20 rule right 80 of your time and
data science workflows is typically
cleaning up the data your data
preparation and 20 for everything else
and that's definitely the case when
you're working in graphs uh graph data
science and in fact maybe even more so
problem though
is that the work that you have to do in
data preparation for graphs typically
must be done Upstream of being loaded
into some sort of graph database so I'll
say that again the hard part of cleaning
up the data graph data so that you can
use it in Knowledge Graph actually that
needs to be done a lot of it before you
even load it into any sort of a database
and that really runs contrary to a lot
of vendors you have sort of one size
fits-all claims where they do everything
the reality is there's a lot of
preparation and and it may be very
expensive kinds of work especially where
you have graphs that are measured in
millions and billions and trillions
um so I want to give a sampler for some
of these kinds of graph data preparation
and what you should be aware of when
you're doing this kind of work and also
just some tools and techniques that are
really useful so first one is
deduplication
um if you have a graph that has you know
millions or billions of elements and
some of those are really important but
they occur many times because they
haven't been deduplicated then there's
not going to be a lot of connectivity or
predictive power out of the graph so you
need to be able to find the things that
are similar and if they indeed are the
same entity merging together
if they're not quite the same entity
disambiguate them and these tend to be
very high dimensional kinds of problems
um there's some great tools data sketch
is excellent for probabilistic data
structures approximation algorithms as I
say there's name match you can train
models for disambiguating names and of
course there's all the nearest neighbor
work different types of algorithms
inside of scikit-learn and related and
and frankly this is a really good area
too for a lot of deep learning such as
graph neural networks
um and I anticipate seeing a lot more
here this is a hard problem because if
you're deduplicating hundreds of
millions of entities and it's something
that requires similarity analysis and
other kinds of lookups you can get into
a really complex expensive problem
pretty quickly
um there's also the matter of unique
identifiers if you have unique items
within a graph they need to have some
sort of identifier to to to uh be able
to refer to them uniquely and of course
uuids work in a lot of cases if it's
just strings but there's a lot of times
when you're working with graph data when
you have to transform say into a very
large sparse Matrix do some calculation
and then transform the results back out
into your graph and so there you really
can't use uuids you need to have numeric
representation and so you do run in this
problem in Industry a scale of having to
assign unique identifiers
um there's some great tools kiwi uh
works with Finance state transducers so
you can do in-memory immutable fsts for
really fast lookups that's kind of what
the diagram is showing here and also
redis is like the the Swiss army knife
in this area too I use redis so much for
this
another area that may be kind of
counter-intuitive is something called
cycle detection and this is actually the
problem that plagues a lot of people
when they get into doing graph data
science work
um in a graph a lot of times with
knowledge graphs we're working with
what's called a directed graph so a
points to be B points to D there's
arrows
um Sometimes some types of algorithms
you'll use undirected graphs
um
one of the problems may be that the the
arcs are wrong or the direction is wrong
in your data so for instance if you were
representing a family tree you know um
the fact is distance cousins do marry so
family trees are typically graphs not
trees
but you you would think that these are
acyclic graphs okay somebody's
some individual children are not in turn
also their grandparents
um and the same thing happens when
you're looking at shipping containers
and manifest data in uh in Industry
um you really don't want to see the same
shipping container going back and forth
between two warehouses but it happens a
whole lot and it's a it's a cost sync
it's a problem
um and certainly in accounting and
e-commerce and finance there's a lot of
fraud that goes on because of cycles
that really should not be there so um
detecting the Cycles in your graph at
scale it's a difficult problem you can
use breath research in other ways
um but you need to be able to resolve it
before you can really go in and do the
inference that you need to do and
then next is something called transitive
closure this is where if you've ever
worked in uh object-oriented languages
that have class inheritance like python
or Scala Java Etc
um there's this idea of being able to
inherit from parent classes and so in
the graph space this is referred to as
transitive closure it's the kind of
operation that you do to propagate the
inherited properties through a graph
and typically you need to do that before
you can really run certain types of
queries or certain types of analysis for
them to be correct
um if you've ever tried to perform
transfer closure inside of relational
databases scale anything non-trivial in
terms of size you'll find that the thing
comes crashing down or maybe takes hours
and hours before uh query returns uh
this is something called the self-join
problem because to be able to do this
you need to hop through links in a graph
and typically in a relational database
that means you're doing a self-drawn
you're joining a table to itself over
and over and over again and it usually
brings the indexes Crashing Down
um there's some really useful tools like
lrl
um that we've been using to to manage
transitive closure
um but it's something you have to be
aware of
another thing is that a lot of times
when you're bringing in data you may not
know in advance what's actually linked
you may get raw data so a classic
example is somebody gives you a whole
bunch of network security logs and in
fact I mean in the network security
space that's kind of like a capture the
flag competition they just give you a
big log data set like a Kegel data set
and then you have to figure out how the
things that need to be linked should be
linked
um so this happens a lot with grasses
you have to build them up probably from
some raw structure unstructured data
and there are some techniques for this
um one of the most popular is called
umap it's a kind of visualization
technique it's it's for manifold
analysis for dimensional reduction and
similar to T snake if you've ever seen
that but it also shows how data should
probably be linked
um over on the right hand side there's a
diagram of doing some genetic genomic
analysis different types of genes being
expressed that are related to each other
um showing how they could be linked in a
graph there's a really excellent
tutorial about this on this umap library
that I linked it's called how umap works
now opposite of this another thing
that's sort of the converse problem
if you're working with data coming out
of data warehouses data Lakes Like
Houses all that the thing that you run
into in Enterprise over and over again
is that somebody had linked data graph
data and they were tasked with
representing it loading it into a
relational data warehouse and they
couldn't really figure out how to do
that what they will typically do is
denormalize the other context so a row
will actually have a lot of data
included for some of its its parent
links and you're the the poker tell on
this is you'll see really wide rows with
a lot of repeated context and this
happens very frequently and it makes
data warehouses explode so when you run
into this the way to build a graph out
of it is you have to go through and
cache the context and then keep doing
lookups to it things like kiwi might
come in really handy here
um there's a lot of uses potentially
this is for deep learning for doing
something called link predictions so
basically learn the kind of motifs the
kind of patterns you would expect to see
in a graph and then when you see a data
object that's missing some of those you
know suggests hey maybe maybe something
is missing the data or maybe something
should be expected here and this is
related to like akbc automatic
construction of knowledge bases graph
bases it's actually a pretty good
conference called KBC
um another thing about graphs is just
keep in mind that if you're using
ontologies controlled vocabularies
um if you've got that as your schema for
your graph like you do in terms of w3c
kind of graphs that's great it's really
useful
um label property graphs kind of avoid
this but then sooner or later they
probably find out that we might need or
want to do that how do we take our
labeled property graph data and then put
it under an ontology well there's a ways
to do that it's sometimes painful
um
but the long short is that ontology is a
tool and it's not always done correctly
the first time it may require some
iteration
um if there's a popular ontology that
you're using frankly a use case might
use several ontologies you'll need to
align them you'll need to make sure that
they fit your use cases you might need
to extend them and even after you've
done all that class inheritance doesn't
solve everything typically we find that
there are multiple ontologies used but
then you also weave some sort of
taxonomy through it for most of the
kinds of AI applications with graphs
that we see that's a common thing so if
you've got people who are really
dogmatic about ontology they're probably
going to be a problem
um you know take it with a grain of salt
understand there are limits to ontology
understand that there are ways to do
post-processing and pre-processing and
even after you've done your graph
queries you may need to apply some
graphml or some post-processing or some
sort of probabilistic rules Etc just to
make sense out of what's going on there
don't rely only on queries and ontology
um another big area is that well for any
large graph project you probably are
going to be pulling some data out of a
data warehouse out of some spreadsheets
there's probably thousands of
spreadsheets in the Enterprise that are
relevant and so how do you migrate that
data how do you do the data translations
to go from say relational databases
spreadsheets Etc and move them into a
graph data model to fit your your schema
your ontology
um so there's a standard called r2ml
that maps from relational to rdf and
then more broadly than that there's
something called rnl which will do
translations of relational plus other
kinds of sources I really like uh this
project morph KGC we've been working on
this team uh shout out to Oscar control
at upm in Madrid and grad students also
working on this uh too many to name
right now but I appreciate you all morph
KGC is a really excellent way to to pull
in sources from say you know my SQL or
postgres or wherever
another thing in data science of course
we talk a lot about data labeling it's a
really hot area because of you know
preparing uh data sets for AI projects
in general
um and there's you know a lot of
commercial Ventures along these lines
for data labeling and whatnot
um also some really great open source
projects I work with one that's called
argila which is a way of doing data
labeling pipelines that um you know kind
of put some Dev opposition types of
things around gingface so you know tens
of thousands of models in hunting face
you can wire them up to flares basically
whatever you're using in Python for NLP
leverage the models but also capture
where decisions being made and also
bring in some human in the loop kind of
uh aspects so you know you might use
weak server Vision or Active Learning so
that you can bring in your domain
experts to clean up the labels and the
labels in a graph are a little bit more
complicated one is
um there's something called extraction
in NLP and this is where we're taking a
look at the labels that will be applied
to nodes and we're trying to figure out
what classes do those need to be what
what do they inherit and so there's some
sort of unique identifier URL if you
will but they're called Iris it's like
URL plus plus
um
and so we need to be able to link into
our controlled vocabulary for every node
to be identified what class it is
and then for the edges for the
predicates that are represented on edges
there's a different type of NLP approach
called relation extraction we're trying
to figure out what links how do we
classify these links
um so there's a couple really great
tools here Aguila is nice for
incorporating uh you know sort of your
your envelopes if you will along with a
lot of popular libraries in Python
and then there's a really great listing
of awesome relation extraction
and just in general you know you're
going to be blending large language
models weeks of revision active learning
for uh you know Humanity practices and
then also sort of the the opposite MLS
type practices like keeping track of
what decision made where and and how to
go back and revise them
um another area has to do with
visualization and graphs um you may have
seen some really beautiful graph
visualizations and I'll tell you when
you put those in front of Executives you
definitely hear a lot of oohs and Oz
sometimes they're a little bit too
beautiful one of the typical problems is
to go out and do a really gorgeous data
visualization of your graph put in front
of Executives and they go wow that's
great we should frame it and put on the
wall what does it mean what is that
little purple dot over there mean and
the thing is that it may be that the
things that look really good in a graph
rendering have little or nothing to do
with the important details of your use
case and and automated layouts really
accentuate this so
um there's some ways around it um there
are uses of graph theory if you have the
math background you can use quarter
graphs or you know various forms of
topological transforms to highlight the
things are important and avoid
highlighting the trivial things you can
also use gnns to find patterns Motif
prediction uh definitely recommend
mustache Vesta and others working in
this area there's some great tools
there's dot Motif there is pi graphic
stream we were working with graphic
stream folks they're really awesome
and Motif minding is going to be a big
thing here I'm going to scoot along real
quick because I'm running out of time
but a lot of room ahead on this
um and then last but not least even if
you've done all of the above really well
there's still the looming issue always
in data science of data quality so
whenever you're working in data
analytics in general data quality is a
concern and it should be a concern
and graphs uh this is a bit more
poignant there's a couple of great tools
one is called shackle and this is a kind
of shape constraint so you could think
of of applying unit tests of patterns
and expected values expected ranges on
data values things like that that you
want to apply throughout your graph and
then basically like a unit tests kick
out the parts that don't pass the tests
um alternatively there's something
called PSL that I like to use it's
probabilistic softlogic and the idea is
you can run some probabilistic rules
through your graph and then assign
uncertainty values
um for you know which parts of your
graph are more believable than others
also you can sort of run that on the
whole graph and figure out how
consistent is this whole graph so think
about this in terms of data quality and
and data integration think about you
bring up a graph and you measure it
probabilistically see how consistent is
this graph based on the rules that I
have for its domain
and then you load another data update
and measure it again and if the
consistency drops well you know there's
probably a problem
and then go back and you know apply the
PSL rules and the shackle rules and say
let's put a spotlight on the elements
that we've just loaded that are causing
problems
um let's get some experts to look at
those maybe maybe there's data quality
problems
so uh Ryan Wisniewski has really
brilliant work of playing category
theory in this area they've used it Uber
and others uh and definitely look at
that for the long term
and we've got some tutorials that cover
a lot of this uh basically there's some
Jupiter notebooks up online that we have
where we show using these kinds of
techniques with a sample from food.com
of a quarter of a million recipes and
you know just some some things to think
about when you're doing data preparation
and building up workflows so that you
can get to the point of actually doing
something interesting like maybe a
recommender system
um in the time remaining I want to add
real quickly we've got a proposed
standard we found in our work especially
with customers that as it turns out
parquet is really effective for managing
graph data and in particularly we've put
together a way of using parquet
um you know to get us a couple of orders
of magnitude increase and it also really
aligns with the ETL tools like spark and
trino and Cassandra Etc
um but we have a way of being able to
represent spanographs label property
graphs probabilistic graphs imports from
spreadsheets imports from data frames
exports to edgeless
Etc all in a common kind of parquet
format so here's some tools for being
able to explore that and use that with
your data
and then lastly
um I uh moderate a group on LinkedIn
called graph data science there's a lot
of people there
um over 600 and um and we have links to
other like conferences and communities
as well if you want to grab the slides
they're here online uh here's the URL
and also a 2d uh
if you want to get a hold of me I'm over
in the fediverse
um I'm pacoid at mastodon.green thank
you very much
thank you very much for this informative
talk and uh we are waiting for any
questions
I I should say the slides there's about
150 slides in that deck that I linked to
um so uh let me um put that back up
yeah I'll just leave that in the channel
so yeah there's a lot of slices a lot
more kill this is a short talk compared
to the rest of it
um but we really go into a lot more of
the business caves and there's a lot of
use cases that are Illustrated in
Industry where they're using graphs for
AI applications uh especially some
interesting stuff out of Pharma and um
you know like drug drug Discovery uh uh
genomics Etc
great
thank you for sharing
certainly and um and I'll just put a
plug in again to you um we've got a lot
of people using kg lab and doing
Integrations uh we're very actively
working with several
a couple of dozen at last count of other
open source projects for uh providing
integration paths we're looking toward
you know adding more or working with
other people so um let us know we've got
a pretty Lively developer Community
working on this and the intent is really
to to make these graph Technologies talk
with each other but also look very Pi
Danish like run a graph query get a
pandas data frame as a result back
so if you're interested in working on
this please let us know
um we're all over GitHub and whatnot
um great thank you very much for this
amazing talk
um there are no questions so if you
would like to wrap up here
okay great
um yeah okay uh thank you very much I
really appreciate and uh have a great
rest of the conference I look forward to
checking out a lot of the talks
yeah
yeah oh hey uh really great question so
who's working on category theory of
graphs that's uh Ryan wisneski uh
whizkey.net
believe this right let me uh make sure
well I can't quite check that out it's
it's in my slides but Ryan Wisniewski
um there they have a company that he's
co-founder of called Connexus Ai and uh
they've been working especially on using
category Theory to do like schema
alignment
um if you're bringing in graph data from
multiple sources how do you make sure
that the different ontologies align and
how can you try to align them more
optimally
um and also just data quality uh
measurements there's some really
interesting things basically categories
are richer than graphs so category
theory is sort of over and Beyond what
you'd see in graph Theory um so you can
use it to really constrain that kind of
the long and short there's some great
talks uh I think I was just listening to
something from Josh uh who's one of his
research Partners was interviewing Ryan
uh listening that yesterday so
definitely look for their videos online
and ping me to
um uh ping me on Macedon and I'll I'll
get some more links for you
awesome thank you
thank you have a great rest of the
conference